complimentary football playing better
coaching better
um
you know when you can run the ball for
for what we did and and hold them to to
what we did that that's the difference
in the football game it's always fun you
know whenever you're able to you know
start fast
in the game
with a w so like i said i always give my
my guys credit guys in front of me
blocking that's gonna go do my job did a
great job today all the credit goes to
them
it's about a week and a half ago that we
had quotes that we played from titan's
quarterback ryan tannehill where he was
talking about the reduction in touches
in recent weeks for running back derek
henry and that it was done deliberately
and it just struck me as odd because
that seems to be something
that a coach would say not the
quarterback you'd hear that from mike
vrable or from offensive coordinator
arthur smith and i talked to danielle
after the game yesterday and i reminded
him of what he said and i said
what changed the last two weeks why is
it 28 carries for henry one week 27 the
next and he said well you'd have to ask
the coaches
but you said so a week and a half ago
you should know the answers to these
questions but you know he later
acknowledged if they're going to get to
where they want to be
they've got to ride
derrick henry period when they got away
from it what happened chris they started
losing now that they're back on the
henry bus
they're winning
yeah it's like they decided for a few
weeks like hey we're gonna use them more
as a decoy we think our best way this
week is to play action and do things off
of them whatever but no it's not he's
special
um and it's i mean i think it's official
he's in the mvp race i mean there's no
doubt about it mahomes rogers
derek henry those are the three guys
right now as far as i'm concerned and
with how they're playing but that was an
unbelievable performance and i know the
colts you know are missing deforest
buckner and and had some some issues
there as far as covid19
but that's still we were going into
yesterday with the colts as the number
two defense in football to just bludgeon
them that way you know and play the way
they did all the big plays that then
came off the pass game really impressive
the titans seem like they've kind of got
their mojo together here and maybe maybe
ready to make a little bit of a run here
down the stretch mike
and i asked tanhell about
playing a team so soon after playing the
first time and with the cults he said
they don't do a lot of exotic things
it's just physicality yeah we know what
they're going to do they know what we're
going to do and this time around you
know they didn't have the special teams
miscues that gave the colts 14 easy
points they they stepped on the throat
early and that was that and the titans
reasserting themselves as a team to be
reckoned with not just in the division
but in the entire conference
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports